At one point, it should have cursed person be concerned about their cholesterol levels.
So, you know, back when I graduated, way back when, the normal cholesterol, I think at
that time was 220, maybe it was even 250 at that time.
And then they came up with this drug called Lipitor, and they got a ton of people on Lipitor
because people had elevated cholesterol.
And then cholesterol became the bad guy that started to get blamed for heart disease because
heart disease, number one killer in America.
So it's all because of cholesterol, and we need to lower cholesterol and got everybody
on Lipitor.
Well, it didn't change the fact that people still had placking in the arteries and still
died of heart disease, but you won't hear that too much in the mainstream media.
And then they thought, well, we could get a whole lot more people on Lipitor and sell
a whole lot more of this drug if we lower the normal cholesterol, they lowered it down
to 200 is the normal cholesterol.
And then they thought, again, well, if we just start putting people on Lipitor up there
above 180, we could make a whole lot more money.
And that's kind of the scenario, we don't want to be cynical about it, but that's just
the truth.
So what is a good cholesterol?
Well, you actually need cholesterol.
Clestrol is not this bad guy.
Remember, there's very few things in our body that is circulating through our streams that
is all bad or all good.
It's all about balance.
And cholesterol is all about balance, too.
Well, what is the normal balance of cholesterol?
Well, the normal balance of cholesterol is anywhere between 160 and really maybe 300.
So I would not actually, when I look at somebody's blood work, if I'm not really concerned about
the cholesterol, unless the cholesterol is, you know, in the 300s, you know, high 300s,
really.
Really looking at it as the triglycerides and you're looking at other things, too.
Remember, every blood, every blood chemistry marker is just giving you clues.
So yes, if a person has cholesterol in 290, that could be a clue of something else that's
going on.
I'm not again concerned about the cholesterol and concerned about the clue that it's giving
us.
You know, is there issues with congestion in the liver that that person is putting out
too much cholesterol?
It could have a genetic hypercholesterolemia where they just make excess cholesterol.
They just don't get rid of it.
That's just from a genetic issue that you can't really do anything about.
But a person can have elevated cholesterol because of dysfunction in the liver.
But far as damage of the cholesterol to placking at the arteries, you're looking at high
homocysteine levels.
That's more of a marker triglycerides.
Other inflammatory markers like ferritid and iron would give you more clues of whether
there's inflammation going on and then arterial inflammation going on.
So I'm not really concerned about cholesterol levels and concerned about the clue that it
gives us.
Of course, it's if it's way over 300, then that's something we need to pay more attention
to.
But it's 250.
To me, that's still normal.
Again, if it's 250 and you have way elevated triglycerides, that's abnormal, but it's not
the cholesterol.
It's the triglycerides.
It's the arterial inflammation that I'm concerned about, not the cholesterol itself.